you don't like
sit down and fucking tell your kid and teach them how to talk right
you just like
have a baby you hold it
it like lives life with you
and eventually it starts to learn how to talk and walk and like
be a part of your life
you play around and shit
but they learn this
we all learn this whole fucking language just by just being around
doing it right
well that is exactly how your child learns love
however you guys conduct love and relationship in your home
that's just the vibe your kids gonna pick up
you don't have to make it really known that you guys argue behind closed doors
because you keep it real icy in front of them
you know what I mean
like they're just gonna pick up the general vibe
they're gonna understand what love and relationships are
because of the home that they live in
so if you would be happy for your child to grow up and end up in a marriage
and a relationship like the one you're in continue
like it or not
your children are watching and learning